I also heard you're a talented
cartoonist see you love dude so what do
you how do you are you how do you decide
what you're gonna toons I you know I its
catharsis you know I've been through a
lot of crazy feelings in the last few
years so I just been doing that and and
I let it take me where it wants to take
me and I do painting and I do cartoons
and it's so it's so wonderful in a year
later it tells you what you wanted it to
say I crazy okay so this this is the
story of the prodigal son to me that's
my father and that is basically every
day of my life when I take the shell off
and I'm born again every more yeah so I
did that one on Easter and I just said
hey let's shake off all this you know
vitriol and whatever it is and you can
unite it again and let's like another
thing that is your vehicle but the the
prodigal son wow if you can put that
back up it's it's it's quite we all know
it's not dark actually it looks dark and
yet what it represents for me was that
we don't think about these stories you
know the prodigal son the the two
siblings that you know one goes off and
gallops gallivant surround and the other
one stays in the kingdom and lets in
keeps it running right until the
prodigal son comes back well the
prodigal son is your mind you know at
any one moment you're either in your
body or you're not in your body and your
mind is the prodigal son or the prodigal
daughter and it goes it goes flight you
know the heart can't go anywhere it has
to run the body and it has to keep the
hook you keep the blood pumping and so
it's stuck but the mind can go anywhere
it wants to go but yeah and sometimes
that's fantastic except when it takes
you over and it takes you and it it
prevents you from joining this yeah it
prevents you from enjoying this yeah and
and all of the things in the walk in the
morning and stuff yeah you know so
sometimes when you're in can I say hell
on earth you can and I have been there
times where you are that's time travel
you're all you you can never really it's
very difficult to be unhappy if you're
really in your body if you bring your
brain back to your body and sometimes
that
what pain is pain is your body calling
you back saying I'm your heart and I
miss you yeah my dad my dad is that that
was I did from a photograph of my father
in his early life standing on a rooftop
in Toronto with his pet rat so Wow my
dad was one of the most incredible
characters that you ever met in your
life the funniest man that ever walked
the earth I mean he makes me look like I
don't know what like a Shakespearean
tragedy
you should about you like you have a
really cool vibe and light about you in
your so welcoming like I've a living in
this show for like five months but like
a lot of times you meet people and
they're they all have walls up and
they're still afraid and they're so
serious because they want to be taken
seriously and it's like it's really
refreshing so thank you for bringing
such a life I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this